[Music]
take
just be televised
stream it on the web but we usually have
like 20 or 30 people
my phone
[Music]
so the various instructors precision
yeah
wait for about two more minutes we're
ready to fill in there
so you do you do to win the fall
semester - in the spring
our next one is on the 60s before
interdisciplinary you get Larry on where
Big John Ford John Ford films last year
we did Orson Welles so years ago there
was an 80 in arts and entertainment
half-hour biography on John Ford one of
my favorite lines ever they should have
clicked with him being interviewed him
back in the 50s by some young
enthusiastic person and this person's
holding up
this is mr. Ford this guy was
crestfallen
okay you ready
[Music]
[Music]
after he just was in the background
because I think some of you guys might
be interested I also wrote a little
booklet in company with another
gentleman entitled the conservative case
against free trade you can find that on
Amazon now I'm afraid there's gonna be a
little bit of repetition from this
morning but this is one of those
controversies it really hasn't changed
500 years which is also something people
don't realize I think economics began in
the 18th century it goes way way back
now make clear we're not here to debate
trade we're here to debate free trader
they're just not the same thing
one is often used as an excuse for the
other just like love and free love yeah
I know I couldn't resist that one but
often i debate this and I hear people
give me long lists of how wonderful
trade is they're like your coffee in the
morning your Hyundai your I don't know
your Chinese food your silk shirts or
whatever I said no I don't have a
problem a trade that's not what's under
debate the issue is whether it's going
to be something that doesn't have an
appropriate regulatory structure so that
we don't have harm
being done by it when we engage in trade
now some economists and alluded to this
before some economists by their own
admission don't even care about the
economic interests of Americans because
they believe in an ideology that says
it's morally wrong to do so now I know
that some libertarians are gonna squirm
about this and they're gonna say that oh
we do care about Americans okay fine on
a personal level I congratulate them on
their patriotism and their intellectual
inconsistency actually reflects well on
them as human beings the problem is that
libertarianism as a set of principles
does not provide any basis for
preferring the interests of Americans
over the interests of people anywhere
else in the world so these are probably
not the sort of people we want to be
taking policy advice from in a dangerous
world now there's a related factual
premise that libertarians and other
people like that have which is that
there's no interest no difference
between what's good for Americans and
what's good for foreigners because they
think they're wrong that there's no such
thing as international economic rivalry
but the fact is that economic rivalry is
something you can see every day it's not
a giant illusion that people hallucinate
and have to be somehow carefully
intellectually disabused of now we don't
live in a zero-sum world which is a
canard that often gets thrown at you
when you talk about rivalry but we do
live in a world in which sometimes
what's good for you is bad for the other
guy and sometimes if you own something
they don't and vice-versa
this is true in your personal life in
your career and it's true in
international economics for similar
reasons now sometimes you hear political
borders are economically meaningless
professor Boudreaux said that in the
talk in Atlanta now the reality is you
and I live in America so if you want to
be indifferent to the economic success
of the US you can just go take that nice
job in Singapore the next
I'm your unemployed so it does make a
difference where you live it does make a
difference where economic production
happens nations have not become
economically irrelevant and they're not
going to be irrelevant as long as
they're relevant to the economic fates
of the people who live in them now that
brings us to second slide this is the
notorious trade deficit we've been
bickering about all day now my own
experience with this is that if you
understand the definitions correctly you
can think about this issue in a very
fluent way and you won't be mislead if
you don't get the definitions right you
won't
so to begin it's just the difference
between our imports on our exports so
America imports roughly five hundred
billion dollars a year more than it
exports that's a big sum of money now
it's a single biggest measure of our
trade problem it's a number comparable
to federal budget deficits it can sound
technical because it is technical but
certain aspects of it are very visible
for example when you look at poverty you
drive through run-down cities and towns
in Michigan all over the Midwest that is
connected to the trade deficit when you
look at family breakdown that is
connected to the trade deficit so what's
wrong with the trade deficit well the
first thing it's doing in America right
now is it destroys jobs when goods are
produced abroad and imported rather than
produced here the jobs producing them
abroad now obviously this would be okay
if we were gaining other jobs just as
good due to our exports but we're not
because we're running a trade deficits
or those an imbalance there so we have a
net loss of jobs and as we discussed
earlier this afternoon
the unemployment rate on its own proves
nothing because all that says that
somebody lost a $30 an hour job working
in an automobile assembly plant and got
a $6 an hour job working at Walmart
people are always going to be working
somewhere you know his allowance for a
recession and expansion and there's
unemployment but I'll never forget
reading in the National Geographic when
I was a kid about how unemployment in
Calcutta is really low that's because
people have jobs they're doing things
like taking someone there they're their
lunch for a few rupees a day or chasing
birds away from someone's garden so you
have to think about quality of
employment as opposed to quantity of
employment now the second thing that
free trade is doing to America right now
is deindustrialization it means you're
not just losing jobs you're losing
entire plants and entire industries
there's a myth being promoted that we're
only losing quote primitive industries
like basic steel manufacturing which
isn't primitive that's a whole other
story half the commentary on this is
illiterate because people are simply not
aware of what it takes to make steel
these days but Boeing is losing the
manufacture of airplane wings to
Mitsubishi in Japan does that sound
primitive to you so here's a list of
industries that we have already lost as
you can see it's not this story we were
told in the early 90s of oh it's okay
because running and lose the
manufacturer of like sewing t-shirts and
stuff and Americans are going to do all
the sophisticated stuff in the world
economy because foreigners are just so
dumb they're never going to figure this
out they're never gonna want the juicy
bits for themselves because we're just
naturally a superior nation and that's
just the order of thing and they're just
dumb no really that's that's not what's
happened these things have been taken
because they're advantageous to the
nations that become the hosts of this
production and the wealth that they
generated now I mentioned earlier this
is a big national security problem
because free trade we means we have no
defense against militarily important
industries being stripped away from us
there's not a single plane in the
airforce that isn't dependent upon
components made by likely adversaries
and because the military and in the
civil and military industrial bases are
related if you weaken one you weaken the
other now China knows this perfectly
well and they have a strategy documented
in considerable detail to use trade as a
long-term weapon of military advantage
against the United States
I'm not getting all conspiracy theory
here if you want to I can't get into it
in detail here but this is properly
documented stuff that's another talk but
they are a communist dictatorship they
are not nice people they are very
disciplined about their agenda of
surpassing us as a superpower this is
not a game now you need to remember that
when we say quote free trade what we
really mean is quote unquote free trade
because trade isn't really free the
United States has pretty much free trade
our tariffs as a percentage of our
imports are about 1% of our imports so
we're very very close to free trade
because 1% is way less than currency
fluctuations and just ordinary price
changes and so forth but it's not free
in the other direction because foreign
nations manipulate their trade in a
million ways what they're doing is
something called mercantilism which you
may have heard of and it's usually
discussed as this kind of dumb economic
ideology if in eighteenth through 17th
century where Kings used to be obsessed
with hoarding barrels of gold in the
cellar of the palace and you're supposed
to have all these dumb views if exports
are good imports are bad or so forth
well no mercantilism is a sophisticated
economic strategy going back hundreds of
years and practiced by our own founding
fathers still alive today
that understands that the world economy
is an arena of international rivalry and
that there are ways to play the game for
your own advantage
now the nasty government's in the world
like Beijing they do this in a very
blatant cynical obvious way I mean it's
just shocking their claims that are in
the press today that oh we really are a
market economy for purposes of WTO rules
which is just giggle inducing ly
ridiculous now other big no it's absurd
it's a state capitalist country other
big economies like Japan like the
European Union they manipulate things in
a much more subtle polite politically
correct way but they still do it so the
only way to have free trade
for real would be to have world
government and I don't think that's
especially gonna be popular here frankly
it's not something I support so how do
they manipulate trade well for a start
they engage in currency manipulation
because if you make it current nation's
currency artificially cheap you could
increase that nation's exports and
reduce its imports China did this for
years and years Japan is still doing it
the entire euro currency is looked at
one way a giant currency manipulation
scheme for Germany because by averaging
out the currency for strong economies
like Germany with weaker economies like
Italy and Spain Germany gets in a
currency that's way too cheap those
other currency countries get a currency
it's way too expensive and you get
exactly what we've been seeing where
Germany is only the only large solvent
state in Europe so in Korea I've learned
if you buy a foreign car it's well known
this tends to trigger a tax audit by the
Korean equivalent of the IRS so people
get the message and they don't buy
foreign cars in Germany the major banks
tend to hold the shares of both
corporations and their suppliers so if
for example BMW tried to buy tires from
an American company rather than a German
one the bank would say and I'm not gonna
imitate a German accent because the last
time I did that someone accused me or
something
you idiot this company the part owner no
kidding will go bankrupt knock it off
so people get the message there are a
lot of understandings gentlemen's
agreement there's kind of cronyism
a lot of foreign countries you call it
crony capitalism it works very well in
their more sophisticated countries you
have arrangements between labor and
between government and between capital
what people do and do not do and making
sure that don't land aktiengesellschaft
is successful at the expense of you know
the United States so these countries are
doing very well they're the ones who are
currently lending money to us not the
other way around they're not going to
take our advice and give up their
arrangements their manipulation of trade
just because we think who are in a state
of crisis that our way of doing things
is better
now the reality is that the u.s. right
now is being forced to compete with
foreign state capitalism people use the
term capitalism very clumsy way because
we all grew up here in the Cold War
where there's communism was capitalism
and that seemed clear well now we have
something a little more subtle and much
worse which is we have a rivalry between
more or less free-market capitalism the
u.s. is not a complete free-market but
as things go it's not unreasonable to
use the term and then you have state
capitalism where you basically have
massive government ownership and control
of the corporate sector now any number
of people will tell you this cannot work
and you can write beautiful
ideologically impressive essays
explaining why it will never work I'm
sorry it does work I wish it didn't
because then we wouldn't have the
problems we have but the fact is that
countries the practice this are getting
very rich now the pictures up behind me
are we have our stock exchange which is
where capital among other things is
sorry among other places is allocated in
this country China has a Ministry of
Commerce Japan as a Ministry of Finance
that's how things work I'm sorry so
logical questions why the US doesn't do
something about his trade problem in
large part this is because American
multinational corporations simply aren't
American companies anymore they get
given a kind of pass because they're
headquartered here but frankly this is
frequently just the location of the CEOs
office they like this situation just
fine the Chinese like it just fine they
don't send their own lobbyists to walk
the halls of Congress they send
lobbyists hired by American
multinational corporations who do what
they want it works perfectly well for
them now we talked about the trade
deficit before why it doesn't matter
supposedly no it does matter everybody
likes the story it doesn't matter
because everyone likes a free lunch dad
you can get stuff for free now this is
gonna be repetitive but got to repeat it
because it's so important the key to
understanding the trade deficit is that
when we get goods from abroad Goods mean
goods
services when we get stuff from abroad
there's only three ways we can get it we
have to give something back unless we're
trading with Santa
it's either goods we produce today goods
we produced yesterday or goods we
promised to produce in the future that
is it anything that looks like a fourth
alternative is really just some
repackaging of those three goods we
produce today that means we get Toyota
cars from Japan and we sell a Japanese
Boeing aircraft goods we produce
yesterday means we're selling off
existing wealth like shares of IBM or a
house in San Diego or or something any
anything of value you can sell and goods
we promise to produce in the future
means we go into debt that is you give
me the money now and I'll give you money
in the future this is exhaustive now
what this means is that when we run a
trade deficit that is to say when we do
not require our imports with exports of
equal value we must be doing those two
things either Goods we produced
yesterday or goods we promised to
produce tomorrow so either we're selling
off assets or going into debt now why is
this a bad thing it's very simple it's
not even economics it's just accounting
when you have fewer assets and more debt
you own less and you owe more your
wealth is less that's really it now we
talked before about deindustrialization
and job loss that's the other effect but
just to get clear on the trade deficit
no matter what else happens we owe more
and we are less now one thing you get
thrown at you is free trade is the
American Way sweet land of liberty etc
etc and it's tempting to believe this
it's an easy issue to wrap the flag in
but the problem is every one of the
presidents on American money was a
protectionist the founding fathers were
protectionist Lincoln was a
protectionist Teddy Roosevelt was a
protectionist the US was a tariff
protected economy openly and explicitly
from its founding until after World War
two
Alexander Hamilton the guy on the $10
bill the only guy he wasn't a president
who's on money
the first Treasury Secretary of the
United States the one economist among
the founding fathers he understood that
if the US had had free trade it would
simply end up as an agricultural
appendage of Europe which was the
economically advanced portion of the
world at the time
so we embraced protectionism in order to
become an industrial power in her own
right the logic of this is the same
logic by the way that England itself
used when it was a backwater to become a
serious economic power starting under
King Henry the seventh it's the same
logic South Korea used after the Korean
War to rebuild its own economy and
become almost a developed nation as it
is today the principles if you look at
economic history they don't change the
pattern is very consistent and yet the
scary part of the pattern is that
nations at the top of their game like
Britain in the 19th century can acquire
the illusion that free trade is a good
idea and the Brits embraced free trade
in the 19th century and they went into
decline relative to the United States
and Germany which were still
protectionist and now the United States
has embraced free trade at the moment
that we were at the top of our game
by the way that's very important you see
when I sat down nearly 10 years ago now
to write my book I knew that America's
history had started out protectionist so
I was very curious one of the questions
I wanted to research was where's the
inflection point where did America
change his mind why what discovery by
what economists at what university
suddenly revealed this policy had been a
mistake and we all have to be free
traders now I discovered it never
happened what happened was after World
War two when we had to prop up and
rebuild Europe and the countries in East
Asia against the communist threat we
threw our markets open to the rest of
the world for political reasons not
because we'd suddenly had a change
of heart of the akan the economics and
at the time we were so invincible eeehh
Kannamma Clee strong I mean remember the
u.s. is half of the world economy in
1945 and if you leave out the communist
part of the world economy in 1945 the US
economy is larger than the entire rest
of the world economy put together so we
thought we could do anything and it for
a few years we probably could but it was
a political decision there was no
economic discovery we ever made that
free trade was better than protectionism
it was purely politics
now just want to make clear I'm the last
guy on earth who's in favor of stupid
forms of protectionism and I'm well
aware of the fact that they exist I was
chatting to some people the reception
about us sugar policy because the u.s.
the one thing that the US hasn't really
protectionist policy on his sugar and
the interesting thing is that the US had
a protectionist policy and sugar you
know going back more than 100 years I
don't really know why I dunno it didn't
make sense when McKinley was president
and it doesn't make sense today so I'm
not in favor of any of that in my book I
said what you want you wanted rebalance
our trade so you get rid of the trade
deficit so you have imports and exports
are equal and probably the best way to
do that is with a flat tariff if you had
a flat tariff of say 20% on all imports
you would relocate the production of
sophisticated goods like LCD flat panel
displays from South Korea and Japan back
to California you would not relocate the
production of t-shirts from Guatemala
and the Philippines back to New York
because the difference in wages is too
great what that tells you is a flat
tariffs would have approximately the
effect that you want to have you don't
need to have a lot of subtlety and
finesse and possible political
corruption in what you do in order to
get the policy that you want and so
there is the possibility of
straightening out this mess without
blundering into an economy that's just
hopelessly meddled with by government
setting tariff rates which I'm well
aware is a possibility but we don't have
to go in that direction by the way if
you want to talk about political
mischief trade agreements like NAFTA or
even worse than free trade itself now
they're not really free trade agreements
anyway given that America had basically
already opened its markets and foreign
nations have no intention of doing so
these treaties are mainly about
protecting property rights foreign
investors patents copyrights and so
forth but the WTO has a totally failed
track wreck
at enforcing free trade on nations that
don't want to practice it it has an
effect on countries like the United
States that have serious legal systems
in the rule of law has basically no
effect at all in countries like China
however these free trade Minh do enable
unelected foreign judges to interfere
with the right of Americans to make our
own laws our agreements under investor
state dispute settlement with NAFTA or
under the WTO enable these panels of
experts to decide whether certain
American policies are legitimate or not
I personally view that as outright owns
constitutional at the very least it's
undemocratic and I think on American so
it's a threat to our sovereignty it's a
threat to American democracy it's a
threat to things like our environmental
laws and our laws designed to protect us
against another financial crisis so even
if you're in favor of free trade itself
you should still oppose trade agreements
like NAFTA now I want to finish by
talking about something which I left at
the end because didn't know how much
time that was going to be and this is a
little bit technical but I did want to
tell you for those of you who are
studying economics in school or those of
you who may be intimidated by the
appearance that there is solid technical
economics on the side of free trade the
key theory we're talking about here is
the so-called theory of comparative
advantage which is basically a
mathematical distillation of all these
things the professor Boudreau who's
talking about
potatoes and tomatoes and swapping this
and your neighbors and people in Mexico
whatever if you mathematize that and
then claim it's a good thing you get
theory of comparative advantage which
goes back to the 19th century British
economist called David Ricardo now the
theory in and of itself is fine the
problem is it rests on hidden
assumptions and identified eight in my
book free trade doesn't work that it has
it makes assumptions like trade is
broadly balanced over time but it's not
the US has had a chronic trade deficit
for decades now
either the theory is wrong because
that's what the theory says should
happen or if it treaters an assumption
the assumption is wrong then the theory
doesn't hold so it falls apart if you
look at it in detail
it also assumes the capital isn't mobile
between nations which it is
interestingly David Ricardo who invented
this theory in 1817 admitted that if
capital is mobile between nations and
the theory doesn't hold so as I said if
you scrutinize the sophisticated
theories underlying all this they do
fall apart this economists don't want to
talk about that they usually kind of
snow you with overly technical
mumbo-jumbo trend unless you know
exactly how to call them on it
and I'm gonna get nasty some of them and
some of them are honest and say ok ok I
believe in free trade but yes they do
exist conditions under which it doesn't
work is there ok well are we in those
conditions now well I don't know well we
have 400 billion dollar your trade
deficit
so another assumption is that it doesn't
matter what industries you have all
industries are equal value so if imports
in one industry kill off a bunch of
workers about factories well they're
just gonna go do something else those
workers will go produce something else
well the reality is maybe they will and
maybe they won't it's not a guaranteed
thing it's especially not guaranteed
when you combine free trade with pseudo
free trade which is free on one side not
on the other and a deliberate domestic
strategy of foreign governments to do
things like steal American intellectual
property how many of you remember Nortel
used to be a big manufacturer of
computer equipment routers switches and
stuff they were basically wiped out by
Chinese theft of their intellectual
property that's basically what happened
there Canadians so they don't have you
know quite the muscle on their side that
American companies do but that's that's
a cautionary tale and the other side is
very disciplined about acquiring
industries all this is gigantic flies in
the ointment of free trade the theory
doesn't work if you have a thumb on the
scale at all these points
ah one final thing I'll leave you with
the assumption is made the trade has no
effect on income inequality now I am NOT
particularly a partisan guy left or
right so I'm not going to do a hard
position on income inequality is good
bad or whatever but I can tell you that
trade has huge effects distributional
effects on income so if you think that
it's just okay to have free trade
because it's not going to affect your
workers as opposed to the high income
population it's not going to affect
labor as opposed to capital it has huge
effects and the interesting thing the
really interesting thing is the
possibility that free trade can make
most people worse off by affecting
income equality that can be true even if
all the other good things they say about
free trade are right and then if they're
not it's even worse so I think that's
the end of my talk and it's your turn
[Applause]
thank you thank you and it's a momentous
day at Hillsdale we learn that
government officials are really good at
intervening into the economy we learn
that government officials can make an
economy run better than free-market
principles we particularly government
officials in communist countries
communism has a splendid track record
apparently at threatening America I want
to say a few things about I don't only
have time for only have ten minutes and
there's a lot that I want to say let me
start by saying that the
characterization of comparative
advantage is demonstrably incorrect
comparative advantage when David Ricardo
did first explain it in 1817 was
explained using a certain number of
assumptions
however comparative advantage does not
depend upon any of the assumptions that
Ian claims it is based upon capital can
be mobile and comparative advantage
still works so to to us well here's an
example we in the United States trade
capitals mobile between states within
the United States Michiganders trade
freely with indiana's and capital is
mobile between Michigan and Indiana and
has been for quite a long time and yet
comparative advantage never though
nevertheless explains the specialization
of production in Michigan and Indiana
and the trade there I have never
understood it apparently David Ricard
was not a good writer unfortunately but
they have people since Ricardo who is
explained comparative advantage
reasonably well and I just sure you that
that them instead description of
comparative advantage is simply
incorrect it's it's it's just not it's
not correct
let me show you some other pictures here
so about the capital stock we're told
that the trade deficit reduces America's
wealth this is the capital stock in
inflation-adjusted terms from nineteen
sometime 1945 I believe until today it's
going up pretty steadily there seems to
be no change in its growth at the time
when the US trade deficit began to rise
you would think that if the trade
deficit were this draining of capital
from America that this capital stock
would fall and I remind you that as I
pointed out earlier this is household
wealth in America the wealth of
households it doesn't seem to be drained
by the trade deficit this is a picture
of manufacturing the the Green Line is
manufacturing employment manufacturing
employment has been declining since the
late 1970s in the same way that
agricultural employment in the United
Stated States has been declining since
the 1820s it we workers have left the
agricultural sector and moved into other
sectors which is one reason why we are
so wealthy now they're leaving the
manufacturing sector entering into other
sectors which is why our wealth keeps
increasing the yellow line is it's hard
to see where you are I know but the
yellow line from 1985 until today I
don't know how the yellow line shows
Manufacturing rising so the
deindustrialization that is claimed
doesn't seem to be borne out by the
facts the u.s. capital stock seems to be
rising and US manufacturing employment
it's giving us manufacturing output is
rising this is manufacturing value-added
from 1990 until today value added by
manufacturing firms located in the
United States it too has been rising it
of course dipped during the Great
Recession
anybody want to guess when you gonna
have to guess because you can see the
picture up there when the service sector
became the single dominant sector of
employment in the United States services
versus manufacturing versus agriculture
the year was nineteen eleven so people
who say well we're becoming a service
sector economy is if this is a new thing
nineteen eleven is when that trend began
and it's it's still happening as nations
get wealthier people want more and more
services they want to dine out at
restaurants more they want more
entertainment they want more medical
care I didn't know which numbers I would
need so let's look here this is from
1967 until 2014
this shows the percent shares of US
households by income level in constant
1914 dollars and it shows them in
different income categories so
protectionists say that the middle class
is disappearing in America and in a way
they're right but the middle class in
America is disappearing into the upper
class so look in 1967 only again this
isn't in inflation-adjusted dollars only
eight point one percent of American
families made the equivalent or more in
2014 dollars of $100,000 annually 53
percent of people made between thirty
five thousand a hundred thousand nearly
forty percent earned less than thirty
five thousand today the number of
families earning between 35 and hundred
thousand dollars has fallen the
percentage as has the number of families
making less than thirty five thousand
the number of families making more than
$100,000 has risen people are moving out
of the lower-income categories into the
upper income categories we can break
that down differently using rather than
thirty five two hundred thousand fifty
thousand two hundred thousand we get the
same effect but this is the most telling
graph that I want to share with you on
on this point this is these are data
gathered by the US Census Bureau from
1975 allegedly the peak of America's
wealth at least for middle-class
Americans into 2013 and it too shows
there in all these income categories
these are income categories that are
used by the sent by the Census Bureau
less than 15,000 15,000 to 25,000 a year
twenty-five to thirty five thirty five
to fifty fifty to seventy-five 75 to 100
and that over 100 so if the middle class
is disappearing if we're getting poorer
you would expect that the number of
households making the percentage of
households earning income in these lower
income ranges would be increasing
because Americans are getting poorer and
that these would be decreasing there are
higher income levels but in fact the
only the only category gathered by the
US Census Bureau in which the number of
families number of households rather is
increasing in percentage is households
making $100,000 or more households
making less than that or decreasing in
percentage right it sounds almost too
good to be true because we don't hear it
every day we keep hearing that America
is on the decline and keep hearing and
there are certainly certainly problems I
don't mean to say that we live in some
kind of Nirvana but we keep hearing that
that this is this is deindustrialization
we keep hearing at this massive
unemployment we keep hearing about wage
loss and family income loss and
Americans lost unable to do unable to
provide for themselves the data do not
support that interpretation the news
media I guess they don't like good news
good news must not sell but I'm sorry to
report there's a lot of good news out
there and a lot of that good news
is made possible by the fact that we
have increasing global trade with the
rest of the world I think my ten minutes
is up thank you
give mr. Fletcher two minutes if you'd
like to and then questions great things
really are look the u.s. is still a
first world country but as I said in our
afternoon sessions all the question of
baselines if you want to talk about
people who are living on you know the
average income that people have if you
actually look up what US average income
is I don't think you could live on that
you forget that we're all yuppies here
the idea that there are not huge
sections of this country that are in
serious economic plight I'm sorry that's
that is not borne out by simply looking
at aggregate figures that prove
basically that the u.s. is a first world
country which it is other things you
mentioned the astonishing news that
government officials or bureaucrats can
successfully run countries I realize
that that rhetoric is very tempting and
I have no sympathy for meddling
bureaucrats in this country or whatever
but you're putting your head in the sand
if you think that China's system isn't
working for them it's a grossly
unethical government and hostile to us
but yes it is working and it is a threat
I would also point out that I said that
I support a flat tariff so I'm well
aware of the dangers of government
manipulation so as I put in my book
which I mean printed any number of times
it's a formal commitment I can't wriggle
out of I so the solutions probably a
flat tariff now in terms of the
assumptions of the theory of comparative
advantage yes you can relax some of
those assumptions and still have the
theory of comparative advantage but what
you lose is the automatic proof that
everything is necessarily going to be
good for you as for the professor's
point that well we have free trade
between Ohio and Indiana so therefore
should have it between the US and China
all you've really pointed out there is
the place where you draw a national
economic border is something that has to
be properly considered in the policy you
have for a nation depending on what your
size is is going to be different I
advocate a flat tariff for the United
States if I were an Irishman talking
about you know Ireland's economy
obviously it's too small a country for
that to be appropriate there but that's
we're saying that the policy has got to
vary according to the size of your car
[Applause]
I'm Peter Merritt they talked a little
bit earlier this afternoon about
Anderson Indiana I won't use a personal
experience than ask a question I was an
IT executive with DuPont the division
was sold to Carlisle groom out of
Washington DC I had a team of six
American people working for me and the
decision was made that all of it was
going to go to India these were all 70
and plus jobs by Americans all lost to
foreign classification I go to
understand morally how you can do that
as an executive I've stayed in touch
with all of my people I've made sure
that they've all got new jobs inside
this country doing well in surviving but
this is not easy
that's I'm sorry it ended up being more
of a personal statement than anything
else but to me this is where the rubber
meets the road between what you do as an
executive and what is happening in the
American economy I'll let you answer
accordingly no one has ever claimed that
economic change does not cause some
dislocation but two points ekka the
economic dislocation occurs whether that
change crosses political borders or
whether it occurs by changes in consumer
spending patterns within the domestic
economy when the computer revolution
occurred starting mostly in Silicon
Valley that put a lot of Americans in
secretarial pools and typewriter
factories out of jobs there is no
difference I understand that it's hard
to lose a job but you don't here's a
statistic the number of jobs that China
is accused of of taking from America
since China entered the dub
tío in 2001 the number the maximum
estimated number of jobs that china is
estimated to have destroyed is 4 million
that's a top estimate do you know the
number of jobs destroyed in an hour I'm
talking the number of layoffs and
displaced workers not quits the average
number of jobs destroyed in America
every month because of that excuse me to
be just because of any economic change
1.7 million a month now there are also
jobs created every month and so then it
generally during when the economy is
doing well the net number of jobs Rises
but it takes only two months for
ordinary economic change in America to
destroy the number of jobs that China is
accused of destroying over the last 16
years hi my question is for mr. Fletcher
so you talked about how if you look at
the average income in America it's
fairly hard to live on and I think it's
fairly common knowledge that people in
the lower income classes spend the vast
majority of their income and they have
very few savings and I'm like.he
response as to what a 20% tariff that I
think you would admit would raise a lot
of prices what that effect what the fact
that that kind of tariff would have on
people in the lower income classes their
ability to to live well and I would also
be interested in response to the fact
that I'm interested in your perspective
on China because I looked at an article
recently that said there over 3 their
debt is over 300 percent of GDP which I
don't think anyone would agree is
sustainable so I'd be interested to see
how you work that into your statement
that what they're doing subsidizing all
their industries is
okay let me answer your first question
you're a perfectly reasonable question
what you're basically asking about is
the inflationary effects of a tariff now
as I said in my book if you want to have
a twenty or thirty percent tariff you
need to bring it in gradually and if you
phase it in over say ten years
particularly in a highly deflationary
environment that we have and if you take
into account the fact that it's not
necessarily as inflationary as you think
because you're raising the price on
foreign goods but as you relocate
production to the US they're not
necessarily going to have the same cost
structure so yes there is there is a
cost but the countervailing benefit is
that you are going to be creating jobs
for these people and the other thing I
would point out is that there's the
cheapness of imports with an inflated
dollar and a trade deficit that's an
unsustainable and artificial thing which
is going to come to a nasty end at some
point anyway if you gradually phase in a
tariff what you're basically doing is
you're phasing out the cost of getting
rid of that delusory free-lunch and
you're phasing it out in a way that
benefits us and those under our control
now with respect to your issue with
China and the huge debt levels in China
we've been hearing for years and years
and years that China was headed for a
crash there was a book by Gordon Chang
in 2005 the coming collapse of China I
don't see that seems to have happened
you have to understand that particularly
when you're looking at the financial
system of the East Asian states
particularly countries have very
peculiar financial systems like China
and Japan debt doesn't have the same
meaning there as it does here because
for a start
a lot of that debt is intergovernmental
debt so it's just a basically an
accounting convention between government
and entities they also have a very
tightly regulated financial system
that's not susceptible to the kind of
volatility that ours has so all
obviously they like anybody else are
capable of having an excessive level of
debt whether 300 percent of GDP is that
for them just because it would be an
absurd number for us does not hold first
off can hear me okay okay first off
thanks for both you coming to you coming
to Hillsdale I've been to about 35
countries in my life everywhere I've
ever gone the old Yankee dollar was
always welcomed at least until the last
20 years in Europe but professor boo
drove my question specifically to you
but I like both you to address it when I
when I is an Americans spend my Yankee
dollars overseas on anything I'm kind of
depleting the you know the accumulated
capital of America that money leaves and
in your example of Mexican tomatoes it
seems to me there's a large kind of a
shadow economy of Yankee dollars out
there in the world or a professor per
drill that money doesn't necessarily get
repatriated to America and come back to
us ever does a lot of those Yankee
dollars go overseas and stay overseas
you know oils were priced in dollars
drugs are priced in dollars there's a
lot of economies of price and dollars
there's a lot of that accumulated
capital of America leave America to
never come back to fold around the world
and Yankee dollars for the foreseeable
future
thank you most of it does come back most
of it does come back but I'll repeat
again the bat which doesn't come back
that's a boom to us you know Frederic
Bastiat another hero of of Hillsdale
I'll point Frederic Bastiat wrote a
famous essay in 1848 I believe it was
1846 entitled the petition of the candle
makers and he pointed out that the Sun
keeps sending light and heat to a MEC to
the world to France in this case every
day and the Sun charges nothing for it
and just it gives all these wonderful
benefits to the people of the earth and
it asked nothing in return if for if
foreigners insist on giving us steel and
automobiles and consumer electronics and
textiles and fuels for just pieces of
paper that cost us virtually nothing to
produce I say let them do it
they impoverished themselves when they
do it they make us richer
when they do it it is not the case that
contrary to what mr. Fletcher says it is
not the case that a trade deficit means
that we are going further and further
into debt again I point out because it
must be pointed out again and again that
the amount of capital in the world the
amount of productive capital capital
that produces things for people to
consume the amount of capital is not
fixed and the only way you can get or a
necessary condition for an outflow of
funds from the United States not coming
back to the u.s. to the extent that they
don't come back too somehow impoverish
the United States a necessary condition
for that to hurt us would be for the
amount of capital in the world to be
fixed and it's just not fixed we we see
it around us daily know nothing about
daily we see it around us a yearly the
amount of capital keeps rising in the
third world even today certainly in
America certainly in Europe in China - I
don't worry about about foreigners
giving us stuff in exchange for pieces
of paper with dead pictures of our dead
states and let him do it I stopped
believing in Santa when I was six it's
not a Santa is it there's no Santa here
it's it's the people who believe in
Santa or the people who believe that
foreigners are sending us something and
want nothing in return it's you who
believe in Santa wait a minute you are
just telling us a minute ago that if
foreigners want to give us something to
get nothing back that's great now yes I
don't think they do it
okay well weed follows from that that we
have to be giving them something of
value in return now if we're giving them
things we make that's great because then
we have an industry we produce a thing
we create employment we create profits
if we don't give them goods we produce
today we either have to give them goods
we produce yesterday which means selling
off existing assets
well goods we promised to produce
tomorrow which means going into debt and
service that is simply untrue that is
what's the fourth way the fourth way is
this is the point about capital not
being fixed when they invest here the
capital stock grows more output from
that capital grows and that's what they
get repaid with the capital stock is not
fixed America has been running a
consistent current account trade deficit
since 1977 with
gotten richer since then if this story
is correct we should be in poverty by
now we're not we're getting richer okay
there are a couple of things that I can
explain - I know the basics like that
okay first there's the baseline this is
how rich we are versus how rich we would
be second with respect to your idea that
there's a quote fourth way when you
describe basically foreign direct
investment in the United States you're
talking about two separate things you're
talking about the creation of an asset
in the United States and then you're
talking us so you talk about the
existence of the asset the location of
the asset like a car plant it's located
in the United States and then you're
talking about the ownership of the asset
whether it's owned by foreigners are
owned by Americans now it's true that
we're better off when BMW builds a
factory in the United States that's true
but we would be even better off if
Americans rather than Germans owned it
because that Americans rather than
Germans would own the wealth and receive
the profits but in a lot of cases it
wouldn't be built at all it's built by
the creativity and risk-taking and
enterprise of those people we don't have
a monopoly on that and and their
enterprise their risk-taking
they don't stop us from being
enterprising and risk-taking these
things add together
one doesn't offset the other that's a
piece of rhetoric so beautiful I could
cry but it doesn't actually oh I could
cry it's not rhetoric
tell me what's what's what's the what's
the lot which would it what is the
logical problem with it the logical
problem is that we're talking about two
separate things we're talking about the
location of assets and the owner and the
ownership of assets and the fact is that
foreign direct investment is great if
you bring these things into existence in
the United States and they produce
wealth there's profits that produce jobs
but we would still be better off if we
owned it as opposed to somebody else
owning it I'm sorry but again that's
like me saying Microsoft is great but it
would be better off if I owned it rather
than Bill Gates owning it but that's
actually true well yes yes but what's
not true is that Microsoft would not be
built if it depended upon me it didn't
require Bill Gates
what you're talking about there is
you're talking about the separation of
ownership and control which is a
hallmark of modern capitalism it's
entirely possible in fact it already
happens every day the decisions about
what get built and what gets produced
are separate for decisions of who owns
the assets most Americans are completely
unaware of the fact that when you drive
down the street you drive by Walmart
Walmart is partially owned by all these
different investors and all these
different places and these pension funds
and these hedge funds and so on and so
forth these underlying financial flows
are what determine our wealth and that's
the place where you have to draw the
baseline and say there's what we own
what somebody else owns and how well-off
we would be if we hadn't gradually been
liquidating our financial position to
pay for imports it's hard to see because
you can't see it just by looking at a
car factory but there is this
subterranean fact of financial claims on
assets which are ownership which are
ultimately our wealth that's what I'm
talking might ask you this the data show
that the financial wealth of households
and nonprofits in the isaacs adjusted
for inflation has consistently risen
since the end of World War two and
continues to consistently rise and it
shows no dip when the trade deficit
Rises how do you explain that well the
data also show that the standard of
living of the average Soviet citizen
consistently rose from 1945 to 1989 yeah
sure but compared to where it should
have been if it had not been a communist
country it's just a baseline problem but
wouldn't you see a change in the
trendline how could you not see a change
no not necessarily if we're if we're
talking about the wealth we have as
opposed to the wealth we should have had
if we hadn't made the economic policy
mistakes that we did make it's perfectly
possible to say oh I have a 401 K it has
a quarter of a million dollars in it
that's great well what if it should have
had three hundred thousand dollars in it
if you hadn't invested in pets.com so in
other words you can see that the data
support my point assuming you can see
that the the data is recorded support my
point but if the data truly reflected
what you believe that we say something
different so the data doesn't show that
I'm wrong the data shows that you
wrong but if the data were correct they
would show that you were right another
beautiful piece of rhetoric and if I
were sitting in the audience it probably
wouldn't believe myself but you've
missed the point which is that your data
all they show is how well off we are
they show that we have a quarter million
dollars in our 401k that is not false it
just doesn't say anything about whether
we could have had $300,000 in our 401k
if we hadn't made the mistake of buying
pets commas in other words yes all right
thank you both so much for coming out
it's been very informative and
entertaining
my question was permission was for a mr.
Fletcher
so how under the tariff that you're
proposing would American products and
exports be able to stay competitive in
the world market expect especially
considering the high taxes regulations
labor laws that we have here also how
will they compete with the quality of
other markets considering that a lot of
these markets that we've lost we no
longer have the specialization in labor
or manufacturing to make them happen
well the point that you you've made
there when you talk about the excess
costs posed on American industry by
over-regulation that actually tends to
support my way of thinking because for
example if you have steel business and
then you impose pollution controls they
had $10 a ton well if you don't have
controls on imports you're just going to
end up shifting production to China
where they have no pollution controls at
all and you're going to make the
pollution problem even worse so that's
actually an argument for protectionism
what you just gave us so one problem
with that is I so I agree that these as
I think Ian does as well that these
regulations are often a problem but then
when you use a tariff to protect the
industries that are so regulated you
mask the problem you hide from the
economy you hide from the from the
voting populace the fact that these
policies are doing damage and I would
prefer a policy that reveals the damage
my wall my colleague Walter Williams
drove this point home to me that tariffs
mask the ill effects of bad regulatory
and tax policies here at home if
didn't have the tower just give me three
if we didn't have the tower so we get
more open global competition the
harmfulness of those bad regulatory and
tax policies would be more evident and
we would perhaps have fewer of those bad
policies question thank you very much
for coming both of you my question is
for professor Fletcher so we talked a
bit about creative destruction as
economists and dr. Boudreaux alluded to
this he mentioned this in his speech
about how you know if we had we've had
these industries such as you know the
polio vaccine that wasn't created and
came along and it wiped out entire
industries you know the nurses that were
there to take care of them and you know
all of these industries but we had this
vaccine that you know obviously saved
millions if not billions of lives so how
is it that we cannot equate the creative
destruction story to the trade story
because you get the same thing with
trade when you get improved technologies
from overseas
that you know you showed that list in
your in your speech that showed all of
these destroyed industries but I think
what's missing is that there's improved
technologies that came to replace those
industries so how do you
I guess combat the creative destruction
in your line of argumentation okay that
that's a legitimate point but I can
answer it the first thing is I never
said I was against trade I'm against
free trade more specifically I'm against
quote free unquote trade so I'm not in
favor of a world where we don't have
access to innovative technologies from
foreign countries
second thing is you talk about creative
destruction which comes from Joseph
Schumpeter there's a danger in economics
when you're studying economics of
falling so in love with certain concepts
I mean creative destruction is a really
exciting concept it enables you to beat
up a lot of Deadwood liberals etc etc
that you forget it's not the only logic
that applies to the city the situation
and the other logic that I described for
example with the trade deficit with the
issues of deindustrialization and so
forth that is also a part of the picture
well sure if you'd like well I'll just
say one thing I uh just brought this
book with me it's called for free trade
and it's a series of essays on free
trade very vigorous defenses of free
trade authored that was speeches
delivered by one of history's great
advocates of free trade is a man named
let me see here
Winston Churchill for free trade just
FYI I don't know if you guys realize
this but if you know your British
history you know that my cat knows more
economics of Winston Churchill did he
was probably the worst chancellor of the
exchequer of the 20th century number one
thing I would ask you to remember is is
first there is no free lunch the trade
deficit is real money and the number two
thing I'd like to ask you to remember is
America's heritage the founding fathers
the entire history of this country going
from a third-world backwater to the
greatest industrial power in the world
was protectionist please join me in
thanking our panel
they could thank you both very much our
hospitality will begin upstairs and we
can keep debating over drinks
thanks that I've never seen